[Music]
seong still gets me every single time
now Bette Midler's 1988 classic beaches
and being remade with idina menzel from
wicked and me along now 80 on lines lien
Aguilera just sat down with both ladies
to find out how do you recreate such an
iconic tearjerker
it's a big risk you know to do a to
remake a film that is beloved and
respected and it's timeless this is a
daunting thing for us because we wanted
to do right by it and we know that a lot
of people are out there saying like
don't mess with it
the original beaches starring Bette
Midler and Barbara Hershey about two
lifelong friends became an instant cult
classic lifetime says the reason for the
remake is to introduce the iconic story
to a new generation I thought it was a
beautiful movie - and something
beautiful lives on and it keeps it get
seen by different people and interpreted
differently and more in a different way
[Music]
in a day and age of reunions and reboots
I'm curious to know how you would feel
if they were to do a reboot of wicked
well they're gonna do a movie of wicked
and I'm told I'm not gonna be in it and
I'm angry and I'm spiteful about I
actually got to start the Broadway
veteran plans to make Midler proud the
remake will include new songs in
addition to favorites like the Grammy
winning wind beneath my wings which
became even more iconic than the movie I
grew up singing that song because I was
a wedding and a Bar Mitzvah singer so
that was one of the most requested songs
at every celebration so Bette has been
with me in more ways and than she knows
and with her recent engagement to actor
Aaron lor we had to know its wind
beneath our wings gonna be your first
how's the wedding planning going it's
not really I mean it I mean I love my
man everything's going well I just I
don't know when and I don't know what I
said yes that's all that matters
[Music]
you